[Music]
this is Russia's main Evening News
Bulletin on state TV channel one reaches
nearly 40 million people each night but
while Wagner group head of Genny pran's
death in a plane crash north of Moscow
made headlines around the world here at
home it isn't mentioned until about 15
minutes into the newscast a brief report
says only that Wednesday's crash killed
all 10 people on board and an
investigation is ongoing the contrast to
coverage of pran's death in other parts
of the world is
striking have not been prepared to this
case they don't know how to to react and
they have to combine facts uh to build
own understanding of what happening
meanwhile on the streets of the capital
mix reaction to the news of the plane
crash yes it's good because traitors end
up like like that we don't feel sorry
for
traitors of course it's a Pity he was a
hero of Russia it's always a Pity to
lose such
people I think it is a tragedy a human
tragedy and a tragedy for society he was
a cult figure people knew about him many
ordinary Russians have paid spontaneous
tribute to prosan memorials like these
have been popping up across Russia this
is the Church of St Maxim the Confessor
in the heart of the capital it's been
turned into a makeshift Memorial site
for the members of Wagner group who died
in the plane crash this is both a
testament to the popularity of veni
prosan and a message to officials that
despite efforts to downplay the
importance of his death his legacy will
continue to live on as many questions
remain unanswered not only about his
death but also about the future of one
of the most notorious mercenary groups
in the world dorsa Jabari Al jazer
Moscow make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer